hallo mein name ist luca ich bin 22
jahre alt und spiele heute ein spiel für
vierjährige ja dirty farben heißer spiel
das wir heute spielen werden wir haben
hier oben rechts die einstellungen
selbst die sind gesichert mit einer
matheaufgabe vier plus zwei das ist dann
wohl 3
14 das ist neu
da komme ich in die einstellung merkt
direkt dass es wirklich eine app die für
sehr kleine kinder ist wir haben einen
traktor wir haben schweine schafe hühner
kühe pferde und hasen
ich konnte nicht mehr auf ein kaninchen
als kind aufpassen schlamm und wasser
haben wir übrigens auch noch
das sind alles kleine minispiele in
dieser app das heißt ich würde sagen wir
arbeiten uns mal ein fachforum wir
fangen mal an beim fährt und
was ist mit
ach du heilige scheiße
muss ich den jetzt
ich muss dem pferd die zähne putzen oder
was wie
konnte ich dreieinhalb millionen
abonnenten erreichen mein job
wir nehmen jetzt hier wohl diese
zahnbürste und schrubben ihm über die
szene
also wir müssen uns immer wieder ins
gedächtnis rufen wir putzen gerade einem
pferd szene
das hindert mich grad ein bisschen an
den paddocks im internet fertig
ach du scheiße
[Applaus]
was mache ich mit meinem leben so ich
kann jetzt auf weiter klicken und dann
sind wir hier bei den hasen sind wir
jetzt also mal schauen was wir jetzt
machen müssen im hasen sind dafür
bekannt dass die karotten mögen dann
schiebt die mal die karotte hereinkommt
hier kommt auch und das da rechts ist
der balken wie viele noch essen muss
dann nehme ich jetzt mal eine erdnuss
hier die kanzlei essen kannst du hier
noch nie
in die masse nicht sie mag ja gar nicht
was ist das hier auch gras und sogar ich
in das spiel integriert also laut marca
auch und damit füllt sich seinen hunger
oder sein ein sättigungsgefühl auf jeden
fall krasser als mit karotten wir sind
auch mit dem spiel schon fertig jetzt
immer hier im schlamm angekommen
was muss er damals das ist doch nicht
wahr
dirty meter
ich muss jetzt mit ihm hier in den in
den schlamm hüpfen also
ich halte
spiel genauso viel
also gar nicht so kleiner justus dann
hilft auch hier rein und hier vorne auch
noch und da vorne aber den schlamm und
jetzt müssen glücklich
jetzt verstehe ich dass auch wir müssen
eben den schlammpfützen die ganze zeit
drauf drücken und rumspringen so dass
sich der dirty meter quasi auffällt das
heißt hier wird jetzt ein bisschen rum
hier noch ein bisschen rum hier vorne in
der 2000 jahre später jetzt ich mich
waschen gehen oder was sollte das ist
jetzt wohl dass wir oben auf dem dach
diese wasserblasen diese wasser am
wasser blasen wahrscheinlich oder das
wahrscheinlich das symbol wo dieser
wassertropfen angezeigt wurde ja komm
erstmal die ganze presse hier ein
polieren ein paar sekunden später in der
justus ja ich meine so warte ich auch
immer sauber brausen klasse habe ich ihn
gekriegt als nächstes haben wir jeder
scharfem ich glaube das muss geschert
werden braucht einen schönen friesische
was guckst du so traurig wenn ich den
ach so gepackt okay dass da unten ist
nur ein maulwurf hier vorne haben noch
ein bisschen was up stehen hier die
haare nehmen lassen war ganz das heißt
jetzt nicht mehr den rasierer machen
quasi den rest ab so dass sie ganz schön
knackig bist und dir schöne wolle haben
jetzt fertig noch ein schaffell leute
wirst du deshalb das denkmal meiner farm
hat man echt ordentlich was zu tun ja da
kommt schon das dritte schafe nämlich
arbeit so viele tiere so eine große
verantwortung auch auf suchen.de kunden
wie der sich da immer schafswolle hier
wünschen
so haben wir ja gut haben wir scharf
auch abgeschlossen
luca hat auf jeden fall schon so einiges
hingekriegt dann haben wir hier unten
noch die hasen
ich hab doch mit den hasen schon
gespielt ziehe sie gefüttert ich als
bauer spiel nicht mit meinen tieren
nicht muss nicht wirklich darum kümmern
dass die leben
ich glaube mit den schweinen haben wir
noch nichts gemacht was müssen wir den
machen die müssen wir aufpassen dass da
ach das ist eine fliege ich dachte dass
werden weil da machen wir diejenige
ganze kacke weg von meinen ganzen
freunden hier da auf der hand drauf
getötet haben oder ob das er könnte auch
schlamm sein wir schön einschäumen den
guten gustav was will denn die
vogelscheuche dahinten nun jetzt können
wir hier draufdrücken glaublich die hand
gedrückt halten sondern wird sauber
damit es jetzt schön wieder in den
schlaf gehen kann jetzt ist das spiel
gerade automatisch weiter zum pferd
gegangen
das heißt wir müssen wir jetzt hier
wieder die zähne putzen anscheinend
frisst er halt so viel schwachsinn dass
er die ganze zeit seine zähne in der
mannschaft aber damit sind wir jetzt
auch schon direkt fällig oder noch mehr
putzen nur noch nicht war bisher
bescheuert leider ist nicht nur was
lustig finde ich würde sagen wir kümmern
uns jetzt mal um die kuh hier oben haben
uns sagt
allein diese kuh entsteht so eine maus
also ich glaube dass ich das hier was
will die post schon wieder also schön
hier die milch raus machen auch schon
wieder geschafft
mensch ich bin echt ich hier bestimmt
jetzt nicht noch mal schaffen
aber seine schon anstrengend sie mehr
verpassen die maulwurf mit den höheren
haben wir auch noch nichts gemacht das
heißt da kriege ich jetzt auch mal eben
drauf was machen sie legen eier und die
acht die schmeißt sich in den korb das
ist wenn ich jedes mal die gehen
automatisch in den korb ja das ist ja
richtig challenging hier muss einfach
nur drauf klicken auf die eier
wahnsinn da läuft ein küken lang man
sieht auch schon wenn man hier mal aus
dem fenster guckt das ist gerade schon
nacht geworden denn auch wenn nacht ist
meine damen und herren muss ich wirklich
ganz ehrlich sagen der lukas bauer mit
seiner eigenen charme da gibt nicht auf
er macht weiter kümmert sich weiter um
seine tiere wie beispielsweise jetzt um
ich spring doch jetzt nicht schon wieder
mitglied das ist doch wirklich auch
jetzt kommt diese böse mutter da wieder
an das einzige hobby von diesem justus
ist die hitze muss ich denen die da
waschen
ja hier nimmt einen ball deine
quietscheente und dann schauen wir
wieder eine ganze etage ein ich glaube
dieser justus hat wirklich noch ein
hobby und das ist einfach im schlamm
rumhüpfen so egal wie oft soll ich dich
noch füttern freunde power luca hat
gerade alle aufgaben abgeschlossen was
auch im gesang gemacht milch haben wir
auch schon gemacht mit der kuh die eier
dass er mir gemacht werden schafe
gestohlen
traktorfahren also hier müssen wir
traktorfahren ich weiß nicht was wir
machen müssen ich habe einmal drauf
geklickt ich glaube jetzt läuft der
motor ja dem motor läuft ok ich muss
gedrückt halten okay das ist wieder sehr
challenging auch jetzt der traktor
weggeführt jetzt ist er wieder da ist
wirklich challenging so leute da muss
man wirklich einfach nur auf dem traktor
gedrückt halten und sie drüber fahren
dann fliegt er kurz weg dann kommt auf
anderen seite wieder hat man wieder den
screen gedrückt also das ist wirklich
angenommen könnte auch eigentlich sports
turniere geben
ist
abgestürzt ja leute
die app wohl einfach nicht meinen skill
handle die sind allerdings wieder zurück
müssen das ganze hier jetzt sehen glaube
ich mit diesen samen hier ein bisschen
drüber machen hier genau mache ich mir
noch ein bisschen war es dann noch hier
vorne lang dahin noch ein bisschen hier
und jetzt mit der gießkanne das ganze
diesen weg wenn's nicht also wirklich
bei mir freunde erfahren bin ich ganz
ehrlich wir machen noch alles per hand
wir haben ihn nicht jetzt tausende
maschinen die das uns übernehmen sodass
wirklich regional praktisch gut luca war
regional praktisch gut ja und da könnt
ihr dann sondern meist ihr
beispielsweise kaufen den zen sich ist
eben abscheuliche freunde den kölner
kaufen und dort gibt es auch diesen
chris mit smileys weiter zukauft meine
damen und herren haben wir um
tatsächlich fast 50 prozent runter
gesetzt mal vor weihnachten einwänden
der ideen bestellen wollte und er soll
vor weihnachten doch an kommen müsst ihr
auf jeden fall heute oder spätestens
morgen bestellen
der wird nicht noch mal produziert es
gibt noch glaube ich 50 60 stück davon
bei der pi freising zu meinem job ist
natürlich unten in der beschreibung
schaut er gerne vorbei jetzt muss er das
ist doch nicht wahr
dieses dieses pack fährt
[Musik]
ich kann dem nicht nur weil die zähne
putzen der bessere zahnhygiene als ich
das letzte was wir noch machen können
das unseren justus ein bisschen umstylen
ich würde sagen den machen wir mal so
und so sieht eigentlich ganz verschossen
in der stadt willich das heutige wir
jetzt auch beenden meine liebe new crew
wenn euch das video hier gefallen hat
das gerne mal einen daumen hoch bei
diesem video da er schreibt mir gern
andere kinderspiele und in die
kommentare
ich bin mega lustig das zu spielen was
kinder spielen weil geistig bin ich auch
noch auf dem niveau von einem kind
[Musik]